[Musique]
nous avons demandé à quelques enfants de
nous composer leur menu favori on y
retrouve les marques de l'éducation du
goût avec un souci évident des familles
d'équilibré varier les plats on y
découvre aussi des indices de leur
personnalité face à la no oe ur et
surtout l'empreinte culturelle de leur
époque
1 l'entrée du jambon cru en viande du
poulet légumes carottes et 7 rue l'air
ou fromage blanc on entre et du pâté de
campagne en viande une escalope on
légumes en europe en cours on dessert un
millefeuille et comme fruit banane aux
pommes fromage de gruyère ou du fromage
de chèvre salen avec des tomates des
laitues poivrons tomates farcies les
gratins dauphinois et la sosuco la
salade et des tomates à la sauce à coeur
joie d'y croire on soupe aux choux
goy sont tous là sa fille quand je
partis pot-au-feu sous far cry est ce
qu'elle a lu calmes du sel pommes
oranges quoi s applique aux albanais de
ton du jambon cru mais demain ça lave un
matelot fois on glass co citons
artichauts violets
ouais d'accord robin navets carottes
épinards et vous aimez les hamburgers
[Musique]
ça
flacon pour toi la nourriture
thème les bonnes choses keyyo restera
dans les grands restaurants
ça me venir là comme moi j'ai chez moi
j'ai tout pour moi - qu'est-ce que vous
avez pas moi l exemple légumes ont bien
beau l'amour huberty qu'est ce que vous
aimez par dessus tout est en vigueur
est ce que tu peux faire j'aime les
choses
les viandes est ce que tu préfères les
plus les desserts les entrées gigon
[Musique]